un combat moustache ouais c'est la belle
nuit les présidentielles jamais c'est la
belle unité présidentielle j'avais ces
labels le nid des présidences je suis
pas juste
[Musique]
mais si on fait un faux départ après des
mois pendant toute la chanson et plantes
et puis après on pas du tout mais bon
c'est la belle de nuit les présidences
et tu veux la guitare qui coupe une tête
de début il ajouté les matheux s'en faut
j'ai pas fait le roulement comme je
voulais on va jamais y arriver c'est la
belle de nuit des présidentielles
faisait pas longtemps
merde j'en ai marre s'attend sans plus
[Musique]
bien comme ça ouais
je trouve très bien ciblé sur cette
chose qui fait qu'en ce mois ci on aider
on est des guerriers tu vois c'est pas
juste un métier ce qu'on fait c'est
comme des papiers en fait de partir mais
oui c'est fedaia d'original [ __ ] de
hockey on en a une bonne on peut la
refaire quick prendre l'avion ou pour
faire donc on parle donc tous les jours
c'est quand on te file une émission d'un
corner
[Musique]
comme moi je suis apaisé
oui à temps
actuellement c'est [ __ ] de sa balle
s'est pris grappillé pire que sarko et
tu bats pour ça mais c'est bosser bosser
[Musique]